في عمان وحدها عندنا ما يقار
388 مليون طن من نوا التمر سنويا بيرما
فالفكر هي ان نحوله الى شيء ذو قيمه
اقتصاديه اعلى من الوضع
[موسيقى]
الحالي كانت الفكره هل ممكن استخلاص زيت
الزيت من نوا التمر وتحويله الى البايو
ديزل بدينا في 2015 قدرنا نثبت في ثلاث
سنوات ان نستطيع تحويل الزيت من نوى التمر
الى البايو ديزل وكانت كميتها بسيطه هذك
الايام في نهايه 2020 21 انهينا المرحله
الثانيه من من المشروع والحمد لله قدنا
نسير اول باص او حافله نقل وطني باستخدام
الوقود الحيوي المصنع المنتج او المصنوع
من زيتنا
وتمر من الاشياء الايجابيه في الوقود
الحيوي انها تقلل من انبعاثات الغازات
الضاره للبيئه من التحديات اللي تواجهنا
كباحثين في هذا المجال اللي نحتاج نشتغل
عليها اكثر في مجال البحث والتطوير هي
التكلفه كان زمان البايو فيوز او الوقود
الحيوي مكلف قبتها كانت مرتفعه الان بتطور
التقنيات احنا متفائلين را يعني ينخفض
السعر في المستقبل بشكل كبير واحنا بنكون
جاهزين في المنطقه العربيه لهذا الانخفاض
عنصر اخر يلعب دور كبير في السعر هو
استخدام الكاتليست او المحفز الكيميائي
اللي يحول الزيت الى البايو ديزل استطعنا
نحنا ان ننتج او نبتكر محفز كيميائي يمكن
اعاده استخدامها لست مرات وهذه تخفض من
انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون وهي صديقه
للبيئه وطاقتها ممتازه ونشرنا في ابحاث
علميه وحصلنا على جوائز عالميه ومحليه
عليها ف علميا هي
موثوقه الان بس وصلنا لمرحله السكيل اب او
انتاجها بكميات
صناعيه كنا انتقلنا من المختبر اللي هي
بروف اوف كونسبت اثبتنا الفكره في المرحله
الثانيه رفعنا من الكميه حتى نثبتها في
الشارع في المركبات اثبتنا انها نظيفه
وتعمل بشكل بشكل جيد والان المرحله
الثالثه هي الانتاج الصناعي بالتعاون مع
مستثمرين يستثمروا في انشاء مصنع ان شاء
الله لانتاج البايو ديزل من نو التمر
بالاضافه الى منتجات اخرى تساعد في اللي
هي الجدوله الاقتصاديه للمشروع نتوقع ان
شاء الله خلال سنه من توقيع العقد انه
يكون متوفر في السوق باذن
[موسيقى]
الله